strowman's had a good year a 2 35 era in
14 starts and he's gone at least six in
eight straight starts four victories for
marcus strowman against the braves in
his career with an era of 188.
and acuna lifts one deep to right back
goes mckinney turning around at the wall
he finds it and he makes the catch and
that is a long way to begin this game
freeman walks with one out and that'll
bring up ozzy albee's
and it's grounded into the shift lindor
with the backhand flip to gourmet and he
has no play at first that ball stuck in
the glove of lindor and with two men
away abraham el monte will be the better
runner goes the throw is off lindor's
glove he applies the tag but the ball is
in shallow center field and ozzy albee's
has stolen his eighth base of the year
oh and two to el monte the pitch
swinging a drive in the air to right
center hustling over mckinney on the run
makes the running catch in the gap and
that retires the side nicely done by
billy mckinney on a somewhat wet track
charlie's coming off his best start in
atlanta this year talked about a little
mechanical change where he was a little
bit
better direction a little straighter
direction towards home plate so whatever
that adjustment he was bring it out
there again tonight because he was darn
good his last start against the
cardinals the pitch
and he struck having kneeled 97 at the
bottom of the zone that was electric
one up one down
83rd strikeout for morton in 74 innings
this year two down bases empty mckinney
sends one out to freddie freeman who
catches a line drive and that is out
number three down go the match one two
three in the bottom of the first inning
austin riley leads off in the second
against marcus stroman here's the 1-1
breaking ball outside 2-1
james mccann just pointed to the dugout
he might be calling
luis rojas and maybe the trainer out
here comes louie here comes jeremy
hefner and here comes joe golia oh boy
but this is one of the last things the
mets need to see right now with the
issues that they've had just in the last
few days and
i don't know strowman shook his head
once or twice and that's not real good
it's just one pitch and shut it down oh
boy the mets could ill afford another
key player going down pitchers
especially right now here's one of the
pitches to riley
and you can see him
and the hip it's that left hip that he
keeps on that's motioning too and it
almost seems like they're trying to talk
marcus into just surrendering the rest
of this game and they have stroman's
coming out but what we'll need to learn
is what's up with marcus strowman in
left hip soreness is the diagnosis
on meds pitcher marcus strowman nc diaz
is going to be called on to do
some long relief
so the braves have loaded them up with
no one out here in the top of the second
inning and looking to do here in the
second what they could not do in the
first inning last night jeremy hefner
out to see if he can find a path for
yancey diaz
puts his arm around it that worked
yesterday for jared eichhoff yes it did
so here's ander inciarte who was not
scheduled to play tonight and diaz
strikes him out with a change-up
so the arm of lindor proves fruitful
again charlie morton coming up and
morton takes strike three call and diaz
is two thirds of the way there
now comes the hardest third the inning
for the braves comes down to ronald
acuna junior 2-2 coming and he struck
him out
masterful extrication by yenci diaz
faces loaded nobody out he strikes out
three in a row getting acuna to retire
the side and there is one man away and
that will bring up james mccann
there's the curveball second strikeout
and it's strike after strike for charlie
morton so far tonight pillar hitting 239
with six home runs the 2-2 pitch
did he go yes he did wicked breaking
ball retires him six up six down with
three strikeouts for charlie morton
again a golden opportunity for atlanta
first and second one out and austin
riley's coming up
on the ground slowly hit
there'll be one play it's the first and
it's in time
runners advanced to second and third the
shift saved a double play there for
atlanta yeah i got the ground ball they
wanted but nobody there to cover second
base riders retired dansby swanson's
coming up
and he swings the first pitch and drives
it to deep left pilar going back to the
track to the wall it's gone a three-run
homer the braves finally break through
in the third they cash in all these base
runners
dansby's 12 homer 33 rbis and the braves
strike first it's three to nothing three
nothing after three and a half innings
charlie morton perfect so far tonight
jeff mcneal leads off the bottom of the
fourth
hit him hit him with a curve ball and so
the mets of their first base runner of
the game bring up francisco lindor as
this pitch is swung out of miss lindor
to an e and strikes out morton has five
of those first walk of the night given
up by charlie morton that'll put two men
on base with one out for dominic smith
swung on and missed strike three
another sharp curveball two down here in
the bottom of the fourth inning that's a
big out and that's six strikeouts for
morton who has yet to allow a hit now he
has to go through james mccann
two on pitch is sky to right and morton
is going to escape fourth inning trouble
still no new york hits atlanta leads by
three we're off to the fifth charlie
morton is not allowed to hit through his
first four innings of work
straw came out late call polar thought
it was outside the ball came back he's
rung up and that's seven strikeouts then
gourmet draws the second walk oh the
number eight hitter albert el mora
junior will be next
and a breaking ball is strikeout number
eight so i cough who made his mets debut
last night as a starting pitcher and
went four scoreless innings and now he
gets a chance to swing the bat it's a
pinch hitter
ikoff tops one charging is riley the
bear head he can't make the play
guillaume stopped at third jared
eichhoff has himself an infield hit
the mets first hit of the game what a
terrible way to lose a no-hit bid and
new york will bring the tying run to the
plate fastball again a tapper right on
front of the plate charlie's got it
throws to first freddy
had to reach in the foul territory to
make the catch but he got it that'll end
the inning they get their first hit
they've left a couple more base runners
and we head to the sixth and billy
mckinney's coming up with one out
breaking ball struck him out that's
number nine what is it eight of nine
strikeouts on the curve ball for morton
it has been dancing and dazzling all
night so morton has now hit 11 batters
and that'll bring up james mccann the
catcher the one-two
fastball struck him out first
double-digit strikeout game for charlie
morton this year
mccann is punched out for the second
time in atlanta maintains a three-run
lead charlie morton back to work in the
seventh
swag and a miss pillar has been struck
out for the third time he's got the hat
trick and morton has 11. and two men are
out
and on the ground dansby deep in the
halls strong throw and freddie dug it
out and charlie morton with seven shot
out of things one hit allowed it's all
working for the veteran right-hander in
back-to-back starts three-nothing
atlanta believe will smith is on for
atlanta to preserve a three-nothing win
for charlie morton and two down here in
the ninth inning and it is up to james
mccann to keep it going
mccann smacks one out to right field
acuna going back it's gonna be over his
head and short hop the wall
and the mets have their second hit of
the night a long opposite field doubled
by mccann well the mets need one more
base runner to get the tying run to bat
pillar at the plate brings the 01
line out to freddy he catches out number
three and the braves have shut off the
meds three to nothing is your final
score charlie morton picks up win number
seven it's the 100th of his career